my name is adjoa and Bernadette
[ __ ] I really like Dakar
there is a huge solidarity that we can
not
measure we are all together we
are in a big family with the
children and everything
I am a nurse at the hospital fan of
Dakar j  love this job because I like
helping people during the pandemic it was
something that was really
really hard for the Senegalese people
for everyone
[Music]
we can't forget that because
we lost a lot of people a
lot  relatives friends of neighbors
it marked us a lot there are
many people who have been vaccinated
but it still remains there are others
who circulate without vaccination
it can be a good idea to
work with Africans and all that
for  that we can have more
medicine
with this we can fight the
disease
we will take the precautions to
get ahead of them
it will really do me good to see this
[Music]
[Applause]